bonjour aller au hall à peu près pas
encore c'est pas évident que je suis je
ne suis pas cinq enfants mais ça va être
vivant dans quelques secondes
ma langue maternelle et l'espagnol jésus
est allé à l'université en argentine où
j'avais ou des ex amant un oral en
espagnol et avant 2006 à montréal à
l'instar yann spagnol ma langue
maternelle
j'ai vomi
je ne tenais pas capable de dormir la
nuit avant et même pendant l'examen car
les professeurs mère est demandé des
questions je pleurais un peu et quand dd
fini l'examen
j'ai encore me sentais malade et gérer
des doutes et les prochains examens qui
était comme une torture aujourd'hui
maintenant je suis ici avec vous et je
suis content chez moi je suis un peu
nerveuse parce que je suis certain que
va dire des bêtises mais mais j'ai su
passionner à propos de ce que je fais
j'ai vraiment croire en ce que je fais
et ça ça les sushis 20 des demandes
escure aujourd'hui c'est de trouver toi
même pour faire des changements à
travers l' art
ces connards bon il ya beaucoup des
différentes notions ça dépend à
quelqu'un tous les dimanches par exemple
si tu demandes aux personnes qui
quittaient une propriétaire dans une
galerie des galeries d'art à new york
ça va être autre chose si tu demandes de
notre personne qui qui fait des tapis en
chine un chanteur d'opéra ce que on
art-thérapeute à l'argentine plaint de
différentes possibilités pour l' art
aussi si tu demandes les enfants autour
du mans
et aux sushis dollar je pense j'espère
que tu es d'accord avec moi qui on doit
suivre l'exemple des enfants et pourquoi
les enfants parce que les enfants quand
il fait là ils sont contentes
il n'a pas peur des décès des choux et
des intrus chypre ou autres personnes
qui voudraient peut-être voter rappel de
justice où viennent quant aux enfants
car quand tu chanter la même chanson je
sais pas ce que j'ai des enfants en
garde encore est encore parce que ça
l'essence joyeuse et il fait des bruits
de musique avec la casserole dans la
cuisine les enfants sont tellement
contents quand il fait de l'art parce
que l'art c'est quelque chose qui vient
de cars chansons dans ses peintures et
ne portait quelque chose même que s'ils
ne font pas ce qu'ils viennent de car
maintenant je travaille avec l'art là je
n'aime pas prononcer je prononce le
débat a fini l'art mais n'était pas
comme ça toujours un quand j'étais
petite à l'argentine pour ma famille
l'arrêté une chose étrange quelque chose
loin de nous pour les personnes
inconnues avec un futur incertain et il
me dit non non pour devenir une terre
humaine digne tu dois aller étudier à
voir en bas khan academy est bon et
qu'en cas d'arrivée le moment de choisir
une école on m'envoyait une école
catholique très sérieuse très sérieux
pour devenir une fille respectable bien
et peu à peu mon âme à notion de l'art a
changé
et quand le moment de choisir mon
parcours à l'onu
cité j'ai laissé la publier la peinture
les couleurs l'acrylique toutes mes
rêves pour devenir un acteur je te dis
non et non j'ai fini mes études mais
toutes mes amis connaissances sur mes
notes
il avait plein de peinture de dessin de
toutes sortes de choses et vient soeur
pour moi j'ai appris
quatre fois les mêmes tables le dam de
plus quatre fois plus que les tables
deux autres pour finir mes études j'ai
fini et que je finis et je voyage et
autour de moi ça c'est une autre
histoire corps que je me réserve pour
une autre fois pour vous mais je connais
beaucoup des différentes cultures
j'ai appris beaucoup de l'art les
françaises se dernièrement mais j'ai
appris quelque chose très important dans
leur vie
l'art est une langue universelle
ils m'ont comprendre ça tu n'as pas
besoin de parler la langue de l'autre
bord pour comprendre la tristesse les
couleurs parce que tout le monde autour
de mende le serment le personne en est
une car hélas bien d'accord bon
maintenant chez en entreprise et la
manière voilà que je suis arrivé là bas
c'est parce que c'est une longue
histoire
mais je vais être plus petit pour vous
parce que je ne chante 40 minutes pour
finir mais c'est là le film toutes mes
voyages ce débat c'est le moment de
devenir sérieuses cm installées dans son
plat c'est d'avoir des enfants ma
famille tout ça bon je me suis marié
j'ai mis ça l'est à vauréal
j'ai vu deux bassins femmes bien sûr pas
que ces maisons
en sont les plus bas et je n'ai pas où
des familles chez n'a pas ou des amis je
suis nouveaux arrivants on immigrants et
les jeudis sommes devenues plus
sérieuses trop sérieuse mon mari à ce
moment-là il voyage beaucoup pour
travailler pour être sérieux aussi et
même et enfants petit pleurait fait de
kaka tout ce genre de choses qui ne sont
pas trop mignonne egée devenue triste
j'ai oublié ce qui qui est témoin publié
qu'est ce que j'ai voulu dans la vie et
quand tout était noir tout était sombre
il y avait les labos du tunnel où nous
lumière mais je pense que tu es une
tranquille va me passer encore un place
de lumière de l'espoir
c'était vraiment triste mais quand tu
penses que les choses sont allées très
mauvais quand tu penses qu'il n'y a pas
d'espoir quand je l'attends de l'émoi
des miracles se passe chez devenu ami
avec trois filles mary france janyk et
stéphanie et l'ayant des mamans elles
sont encore des moments comme moi et on
dit on va se rencontrer pour faire de la
et souvent nous nous rencontrons pour
faire de l'art mais aussi en placo t on
parler de notre misère des enfants de
toutes sortes de choses une amitié
devenu très très forte
on note encore ensemble on se rend
compte de temps en temps et ç'a changé
ma vie est là mais libéré laissait tout
de même aimé choses merveilleuses dans
l'intérieur de moi s'exprimer et chez
avg commencé l'intro peas qui
travaillent règle à imaginer mais pas
rare non
et finalement et j'ai travaillé avec ça
et chez les jeunes pour pour être
joyeuse pour être plus content il ya
plus d exemple où tu peux utiliser l'art
je vais te donner
quelqu'un il ya des chiens qui a des
maladies terminal comme les cancers les
gens qui souffrent de maladies
chroniques
ils utilisent l'ars pour et voyager dans
pour rêver avec ça il ya des enfants et
aux pays qui ont des catastrophes
naturelles il économiques ne sont pas
bons pour pour les pays qui utilisent
l'ars pour devenir plus fort pour être
plus content et aussi il est à des
dessins et des enfants et des hommes
aussi je ne sais pas je travaille
qu'avec des femmes et des enfants qui
sont battus qui sont victimes de
violences
et là c'est une chose très thérapeutique
pour évoluer et sortir décembre de
tristesse il y a plein de sucres simples
l'anxiété pour pour bâtir la société
pour la tristesse ou d autres maladies
mentales
c'est incroyable les pouvoirs les pistes
ans qui en a et plus m'en voulais faire
cécile c'est là bas
j'écoute des gens qui me dit oh non mais
je suis pas un artiste je ne signe pas
très bien quand j'étais petit mais non
ma fille tu as tort est très bon
peut-être d'entre vous il ya des gens
qui lisent quelque chose comme ça avoue
je dis non tout est une artiste péter 13
c'est pas l'artiste qui tu trouves dans
les musées peut-être est-ce que c'est
pas elle la peinture peut être entre de
très bonnes mains
dans ce lac austin dallas et je sais pas
tu dois trouver ce que c'est un ton trop
que pour pour devenir content et voilà
c'est mon message aujourd'hui c'est de
te dire que vraiment si tout le monde à
cette heure sur puis ce petit cadeau à
l'intérieur et tout le monde tu ne vas
pas être est très connu toutes les
révolutions tout les grands changements
dans le monde commence à trop petit trop
trop petit dans la tête de quelqu'un qui
peut être était une enfant je rigole
avec ça parce que j'ai terrorisme et ça
mais enfin je dis moi j'étais petite on
fait le nouveau toit tout ma maman mais
vous aussi tout trop grande on fait tout
petit
tout doit aller retourner à ce moment là
où tout était innocent tous pensent que
tout est possible ici ça la manière
qu'ils ont fait les gens chez moi parce
que on doit trouver la force intérieure
pour des oui je peux le faire c'est
parce importante c'est que les gens dit
je suis capable
si tu crois en ce que tu veux mais pour
trouver ce que tu veux pour trouver ta
passion l'art c'est une chose
merveilleuse c'est tout
excellent cadeau
soyez gentil avec toi quand tu fais de
l'art si tu ne l'as pas encore les faits
si tu ne fais pas encore essayé les
parce que c'est en force incroyable
c'est la force qui va t'aider à faire
des changements grains ou des
changements petit tu vas pourcher tout
va être capable de décharge éléments
même un petit peu le monde proche de toi
le monde intérieur
peut-être regarde à la personne que
c'est à côté de toi regardant des supras
les temporaires des cieux
à la personne à côté de toi peut-être
lui les prochains festivals rock nice où
elle les prochains maya angelou demander
un autographe tête en tout cas peut-être
et saha est possible on ne le savons pas
encore tout est possible parce que les
changements commencent à l'intérieur de
nous à 28 jours at il dit